[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is a boss a manaat' who is William
Graham Sumner professor of history at
Yale University and the director of the
program and Iranian studies at the
Macmillan Center he has taught and
written about early modern and modern
history of Iran the Muslim world the
Middle East and the Persian eight world
for more than three decades today we'll
talk with Professor Amma not about his
new book titled Iran a modern history
it's an impressive tome of nearly 1000
pages that tells the compelling history
of Iran from 1501 to 2009 and it's been
widely reviewed worldwide by a number of
publications including the New York
Review of Books and The Times of London
welcome professor Amin ah thank you
thank you for your very complimenting
introduction well you have quite a quite
an impressive career span so I think
that's important to note that and let's
start with the book it is quite an
impressive undertaking give us an
overview well this has been a book in
making for quite a long time for
probably two decades or if you start
from the inception of the book even
longer initially Yale press Yale
University Press was looking for a book
on modern Iran since they have published
one before but for security and they
wanted to update and get a new one so we
thought that we I can produce a book for
about 300 pages but as it turned out
over the course of years my thinking
about how this book should be organized
changed
since most of the books that are written
about modern Iran and there are several
of them and there is nothing wrong of
course they all start the modern period
the societies in the title it's usually
referred to as modern Iran with the 20th
century perhaps with the rise of the
Pallavi dynasty in around 1920s or
sometimes if they are a little bit more
generous start with the turn of the 20th
century be the constitutional revolution
in Iran and the story is taken from
there on my intention was really to look
further backward and luck write
something which the French historians
would call it long DeRay going further
back into history to the early modern
period at least in order to try to
explore some of the one might call
origins or the roots of modernity or
obstacles to modernity as a matter of
fact to try to put into perspective the
events of the 20th century most
significantly in the case of this book
returned to 1500 that is the beginning
of the sixteenth century but the rise of
the Safavid Empire of Iran and with the
declaration of Shiism as the official
religion of the state both these the
territorial reorganization of the Empire
under a guarded domains of Persia then
its name and the idea of schism being
its religion of the state had a
tremendous long-term implications for
what emerged later on in the 19th and
20th centuries so that basically is part
of the argument or the rationale why
this book has taken such a long a time
frame
and it has so many pages right right so
it is a very huge undertaking how did
you do the research for it and how long
did it take you to write it well it in
the I've been writing this book for
close to do like two decades I must say
and sometimes rather frustrated when
it's going to come to an end
writing chapters of the chapters and
never realizing the end it light at the
end of the tunnel but it was kind of a
pleasure and at the same time pain of of
rewriting the history of this long
period of time the research for it was
in a sense a lifetime research my
earlier now I'm beginning more to
realize that what I had done earlier on
in my first book about the apocalyptic
and messianic movements in 19th century
is mostly about religious history of
Iran and then in the course of the 19th
century my second book is or rather my
third book is the pivot of the universe
is about really the political structure
of the country and not only the country
but country in connection to the world
around it this is the pivot of the
universe which is really a biography of
a ruler in the latter half of the 19th
century and my third book the one that
you and I had a conversation about is
back again to the issues of apocalyptic
movements in Iran Iranian history over a
long period of time so there was already
a groundwork for something like this to
be done but never I done this
systematically as before but I've made
certain decisions very early when I
started writing this book for one thing
I felt that if I would like to add
footnotes to this book extensively it
has a number of footnotes and quotation
citations that is
it would make this book even bigger and
perhaps also keeping in mind the kind of
audiences that would be interested to
read this book I felt probably if I
relegate all of the information about
the sources to the very end of the book
that would make things easier so there
is as you can see in this book fairly
hefty section called further readings
and they've gone over chapter by chapter
almost section by section in this book
and provided an annotated bibliography
so it said this book is about this
subject and said a few words about it in
cases that are actually more important
so in a sense I try to avoid using any
primary sources in Persia because I felt
for an English reader or European reader
not Chinese reader because there is a
Chinese edition coming out it is
probably is not much of a use if I give
them all the primary sources but 18th
century history of Iran whoever wants
that kind of sources has to consult
other research tools which are available
and to which I have referred so as far
as the research on my own case is
concerned
well parts of it was kind of easier
since I have already was well informed
or I hope I have been well informed by
the period but the two ends of it namely
the 16th and 17th centuries and then
from the middle of the from the second
quarter of the 20th century to the
present our areas for which I had to do
more readings and that is what would
take a long period of time to try to
prepare myself and try to
look at it and that's another indication
that's another characteristic of this
book is that it's not really political
history I intentionally try to break
through the conventional barriers
between what usually refer to as
political history socialism or rather
socioeconomic history and cultural
history as you can see this book
sometimes at times intentionally tends
to break through these barriers and you
have a section as you can see all the
chapters 17 chapters are in this book
the four parts 17 chapters and each
chapter is divided into sub sections all
of them are titled in the book although
they don't appear in the table of
contents but what you would see that in
every section for instance I've talked
about the political history of the
seventeenth century what I felt that its
bare minimum that it's necessary for a
for a reader but then I'd given say for
instance the history of material culture
how arts and architecture evolved how
how intellectual trends came about and
I'm not trying just to add them in order
for this to be there but there is
actually there is an actual rationale
for all of these sections to follow one
another for instance in the case of 17th
century which is a period of great
importance in philosophical speculation
in Safavid Iran I have raised questions
about the exploration of the notions of
modernity in comparison to Europe of the
same time period whether a Iranian
philosopher mullahs a draw very
well-known can be compared to Spinoza
are these ideas traveled around whether
because Iran was in contact with the
Netherlands with Holland at the time
through the Duchess in their company
whether some literature
when transferred back and forth so these
kind of questions that I've raised my
that does not have much to do with the
political history directly but
indirectly plays a part in the way that
the society is shaped all for instance
in the case of 18th century much debate
has been in the literature of the
scholarly literature of the 18th century
is about the downfall of the Safavid
Empire which is one of these three
Muslim empires of the early modern times
along with mobile Empire and the Ottoman
Empire and the case of the Safavid
collapse or decline and collapse has
raised many questions through three
books about the subject in the scholarly
books and I try to look at some areas
where with less attention has been paid
and probably they're more important
including for instance ecological
changes that came about in the 18th
century it's this so-called age of the
the Little Ice Age
I add the from the early decades of the
18th century on to the end that had an
impact in the agrarian societies of Iran
and the movements of the nomadic
population that had immediately impact
on the political instability of the 18th
century line and that of course after
all after that I argued that the 18th
century brought about a major gap
between the Middle East in general Iran
in particular and the beginning of the
industrial revolution in the West I've
explored reasons why there is a if you
like a gap in terms of the in terms of
military power in terms of the economic
output in terms of exploration of the
world the reasons for that was really
back to the material culture or to the
way that these societies we're weak and
in the course of the 18th
interesting let me ask you this as
someone who's basically spent their life
looking or studying the history of Iran
when you were doing the research you had
mentioned you looked at the the two end
caps of time so the the very early
period and the the more recent period
when you're doing the research for both
those times did you come across anything
that surprised you or you weren't
expecting or you know did you learn
something that made you say wow you know
I just didn't expect that yes
well let me preamble that by saying that
at the time when I signed the contract
with the Yale University Press my
publisher said okay you were writing
this book try to answer this one
important question why at the latter
part of the 20th century after 70 80
years of basically a trend toward
secularization of this state and to some
extent the society we end up with a
theocratic regime an Islamic Revolution
and what does that mean so okay that was
very much in my mind not necessarily
because the editor had told me but
that's something that really engaged me
in the and then you ask what it such
surprised you probably one of the major
themes that even was for me a revelation
after living all these years of teaching
courses on modern Iran is that how much
this interaction between the state and
the religious establishment is so
crucial in the shaping of Iran can you
cite an example of that yes you know
there has been in ancient times or Late
Antiquity actually a fury that it's
often been associated with the Persian
theory of government in which the true
[Music]
institutions of the state and the
religious establishment were considered
through sisters as to
inseparable sisters actually that the
very instability at the very stability
of the society is based on the
collaboration and harmony between the
distance titute these two columns upon
which the society is rests
it's probably a very conservative idea
which is very country today I make a
modernist notion of the separation of
church and state here is basically the
idea is that these two institutions have
to reinforce each other so what happens
is that in this sixteenth century we see
that the Safa bit states very very
deliberately nurtures and and gives
power and place and respect and a great
deal of authority and endowments to a
religious establishment she religious
establishment that it creates and it
becomes part of the institution of the
states so there are judges they are
juries they are schools pretty much like
law schools in Western examples the
colleges are all basically supported and
built by the state or by nobility who
like the Oxbridge system in England or
like colleges such as ours in this
country very much depends in this kind
of endowments so there is a close
association between the institution of
the state and the religious institution
the jury is the doctors of law those
that are really engaged the theologians
although she Islam country to Sunni
Islam had never really developed it same
kind of an official hierarchy it's a
it's resisted hierarchy as I've
explained in this book now over the
course of time between 16 say
even it's the beginning of this process
and 19th century there is a major change
the changes that these two institutions
that one is really relies on the other
that is the religious establishment
relies on this day by the 18th century
are somewhat separated from each other
they still support each other but the
course of events mostly did the civil
war in the course of the 18th century
the the weakening of the post Safavieh
period the weakening of the state
allowed this religious establishment to
develop somewhat semi autonomously it's
still fully supportive of the state but
autonomous in terms of its own resources
it had its own endowments it's attracted
religious arms from the public
independent from this state pretty much
like its Catholic Church so they did the
same still remained pretty and anarchic
in the social structure in their
institutional structure and in
collaboration with this state this is
the second step up to here for me was
pretty much obvious that this is the
process I think the the aspect that
really surprised me in my research as I
did more in the 20th century is that as
a result of modernity and the process of
secularization after the constitutional
revolution at the turn of the 20th
century which is a very important event
unfortunately not much is known about it
in the West it was much more than a
constitutional revolution it was a real
full full-blown revolution and the turn
of the 20th century the society turned
more secular particularly the middle
classes and then eventually in the post
constitutional period during the First
World War
post First World War led to the creation
of in a more secularizing state that's
the parallel estate and the parallelism
it's really the emergence of the state
public education the new judiciary all
the various institutions that there are
a number of them that were the under the
control of the clerical establishment
was taken away from them so and that's
the new part that although it one knows
but one once we read about it and see
the reactions of the religious clerical
establishment towards that kind of a
change is very remarkable basically the
20th century there are more and more
isolated they were sent back to their
colleges they were still had a fair
number of their seminarians who were
working with them but the nature and the
ad the the nature of their exercise of
scholarship and their attitude towards
the state gradually changes they become
more hostile more critical to the state
than any time before so they no longer
are party to the two days stability of
the society with the said they say don't
need them don't doesn't need them
anymore because it has its own
institutions because it has our own
resources and part of the reason why it
has its own resources is the fact that
the discovery of the oil in the Middle
East basically no matter the very
painful history of oil nationalization
provided in Iran as in many other
countries in the region with a certain
degree of a certain degree of autonomy
economic autonomy which does did not
require anymore the support or the
approval of a what it's been defined as
a backward religious establishment is
conservative reactionary doesn't want to
go along with the values of a secular
society and that in in the
long term by the end of the 20th century
by the last quarter of the 20th century
turns into almost a revolutionary
movement and is the very foundation of
what we would find as Islamic Revolution
so in a sense the conservative
establishment of the earlier times turns
into a radical revolutionary movement
that's what I have discussed at length
in my book that's an interesting
development yes that still has not
really played up because if we like
that's the first time in the course of
Iranian history person because of Middle
Eastern history or the course of Islamic
history one might say that a religious
establishment has taken over the
institution of this day never before it
has ever happened so this phenomenon how
it's going to play out in future now we
are this next year is the 40th
anniversary of there's not a television
what's going to happen from here are of
course I haven't covered it in my book
but that's the topic that it's basically
for the for its roots we have to go back
in so in looking over the course of the
500 years that you cover in the book I'm
sure you've seen some patterns that have
involved in fact you allude to such in
your introduction so I'm wondering if
you could talk a bit about that and also
what you feel are some of the really
critical events that took place over the
course of that time period to make Iran
what it is
great thank you so much one that I have
just pointed that the relation between
this state and the religious
establishment is one it's one of these
trends but it's not the only one if I
want to name a few Iran has a very clear
sense of what it refers to as boom and
bad boom meaning the center bar meaning
the periphery so the idea of center
versus periphery
is ingrained into the person or Iranian
political culture if you go back even to
the Shahnameh the book of the Kings you
see that this this is the text that goes
back to pre Islamic period written 8,000
years ago and still many of the stories
the myth basically reassess this idea
that there is always a central is the
paper the significance of that is that
the mode of the government that
dominated Iran for a very long time up
to the 20th century is this negotiation
between the center and the periphery
that's why the current name of Iran was
always referred to as the guarded
domains of Iran it was not one domain it
was domains and they the duty of the
state is to to protect these domains but
it gives them a certain degree of
semi-autonomy it's kind of a federal
system that allows a decree because of
the terrain because the way that Iran as
a land it cannot be rude like let's say
France or Netherland or even although
even in this European country United's
this very good example of how you cannot
have an entire control from this centre
this always balanced stuff by the by the
period by the peripheries or if you like
by the federal system so that's a major
theme that we can see there is another
important theme that again if you are
asking about surprises you can see
throughout this book dominates basically
throughout this book is the fact that
there is a concept of the self and the
other like most other nations you know
all the nations in the world if you look
at their history there is always the
self there is always another it's
sometimes geographically sometimes
cultural it's sometimes political it's
sometimes the combination of them in the
Iranian case also this is a very clear
card there is the time Iran which is
ancient times it's a reference to the
and this is an Iran the plans that are
not Iran so if you go back into the
mythology of the Shahnameh again you can
see that the distinction between the two
is very clearly made there's always some
people out there that are not Iranian
and there are some kind of a threat to
the very existence of the center
that's why indeed in this book you can
see that why she's am being declared as
the state religion is important in the
sixteenth century it's not my debate
unusual because it happens let's say in
Habsburg Empire Spain when Catholicism
was declared as and of course
Inquisition and the rest the same
phenomenon perhaps to some extent
perhaps as a reaction to Iran happens in
the Ottoman Empire that declares itself
as the Sony power
so she them is important in this regard
because these forces of the non Iran on
the frontiers always seem to threaten or
for the Iranians people inside always
felt that these are threats from the
outside so the sense of the other is
always associated with the sense of
insecurity and therefore there is a need
for domestic internal cohesion and that
cohesion comes through a religious idea
that's the ideology that brings about
the cohesion and so now in reality what
you see that that for from the 50-ton
1600 onwards Iran faces these and Iran
these forces on its frontiers the most
significant the most powerful obviously
is the Ottoman Empire in its Western
frontiers it's a Sony verse verse is a
shitty Iran and of course the O's backs
and the Afghans and the other Sunni semi
settled populations or the States and
it's north west north east
and Eastern frontiers so it said what
they would call an empire to frontier
empire so it has in the course between
the 16th and 18 perhaps even 19th
century you see the pressure on both
sides east and west and the Ottomans
were far more powerful far more numerous
in terms of their armies and their
demographics Iran in terms of its
resources could never compete with the
Ottoman power which was much richer much
stronger or against the Mughal Empire
which was the richest of all and the
richest of all the empires in the world
at the time in the early modern times
none no European Empire could compete
with mobile Empire in terms of wealth
population and wealth perhaps only China
is the only otherwise Indian
subcontinent or mobile Empire of South
Asia is the great power friend of Iran
usually for many reasons cultural
exchange is a great deal but
nevertheless the Iranians found
themselves between these Sony pressures
on their frontiers this is the pattern
which is another significant pattern
Iran will default for three centuries
against the Ottomans and tremendous cost
and the Ottomans were the aggressors for
virtually all the time they are always
in Iran's gateway as opposed to irani as
being ever in Constantinople in Istanbul
it's always the reversal beyond that you
see that in the 19th century there is a
shift because these two powers either
decline or disappear what emerges that
the European imperial powers in the 19th
century and instead of east-west
north-south now you see the Russians
emerging as an expansionist imperial
power in northern frontiers of Iran
let's say from round about I mean before
you get about the earlier episodes from
the beginning of the 19th century and in
the south the British
colonial India that was had its
particularly interest in the Persian
Gulf for what they would claim to be the
security of India so Iran basically for
from the beginning of the nineteenth
century all the way one might say with
some exaggeration one might say all the
way to the collapse of the Soviet Union
in the 1990s has been between these two
powers not the British in the South
disappeared by 1950s after 1953 really
but the Americans arrived as a
superpower in the Persian Gulf they
still are actually very present and
there is a tension in the persian gulf
between iran which always had a claim
over the Persian Gulf and now the
emergence of the Emirates in the
southern shores of the Persian Gulf
Saudi Arabia with the support of the
Americans as we see today part of it is
in a sense is the continuity of that old
pattern of the north-south Russia does
not have curiously enough since 1990s
for the first time does not have a
common border with Iran because all
through the 19th century all through the
period of the Soviet Union it had the
longest land frontiers with Iran with
Turkey was more or less the same and it
was crucial in during the Cold War for
Iran to become an ally of the United
States because of this common border for
other reasons as well so Iranians has
always been conscious of their northern
neighbors and it's not surprised that
even today given the circumstances that
we are encountering with the United
States emerging as a opponent of the
Islamic Republic there is a tendency on
the side of the Islamic Republic to
bring back Russia into the game in order
to maintain that kind of
as late as perhaps a couple of weeks ago
last week when there was a gathering of
mr. Putin mr. rouhani and mr. Erdogan
from Turkey in Tehran so in essence the
question was of course Syria but it was
more than that it's basically to try to
create a new front against the emergence
of images of a hostile United States in
the south so that's another important
pattern that you see in the shaping of
Iran these are they're much more that I
can name but he's a most significant
that I wanted okay and in terms of the
your audience for the book I'm wondering
if you think it would be helpful for
foreign policy analysts to read it well
actually one of the issues while I was
writing this book I was never quite sure
whether it was as the British would say
I was talking to my hat or I was writing
to some audience somewhere sometimes I
was thinking okay this is my for my
undergrads okay if I'm teaching a course
called making a modern eater and that's
the thing that they would like to know
sometimes I said to myself well past
grad students have to really be my
audience at the times I thought well my
colleagues because I've made many
arguments here which is not really the
conventional arguments accepted by the
scholarship so that three audiences are
ready then I thought about there is a
fair amount of American Iranian American
population in this country it's probably
about a few millions now or in the
english-speaking world because it's not
only these countries in Canada Austria
Australia in Europe and English reading
public and they the new generation those
that we brought up in this country and
have this kind of urge to know more
about their past maybe this is something
which is of interest to them and finally
of course as we approach more and more
to the 28 latter part of the 20th
century and 20
century of course policymakers I'm not
particularly sure this administration
but I hope generally people would take
notice of it and to my great surprise I
am really genuinely saying so the
reviews that I received I received a
review an economist in a Wall Street
Journal in Sunday Times as you mentioned
Times of London in New York Review of
Books all of these proved to me that
there is a broader policy orientated
interest toward this book because it
gives them that if you dealing with Iran
you are not dealing with Islamic
Republic of Iran but you are dealing
with something much deeper much more
culturally nuanced with the deep memory
that is that goes back in time and has
not been eroded yet who knows what's
going to happen tomorrow with all the
problems that Iran is facing to the
environmental problem economic problems
and so forth what's going to be but the
fact of the matter is that this kind of
presence of Iran should not be purely
looked in strategic terms that's
important but this geopolitical
strategic locating Iran with its
interest in the region around it it all
has historical precedents the
relationship between for instance Iran
and Iran southern Iraq in particular is
a very old one
ever since the rise of the Safavids
and even before that but in my book
since the rise of the satellites in 16
in 15th and 16th centuries Iran twice
had control of Baghdad so Baghdad was
considered as part of the
really Iranian system and that goes back
to the late antiquity where the capital
of the sustain and empire of Iran was
actually mr. potamia what is today you
see as Baghdad was built on the ruins of
the old Sicilian capital so it's a very
old interaction between Mesopotamia and
the Iranian plateau with the Persian
Gulf the same the presence of Iran in
the Persian Gulf
of course close to the ancient times but
in the early modern times it's the
alternative route that Iran found once
the confrontation with the Ottoman
Empire closed the may trainee a trade
route to the interiors of the Middle
East Iran to the interiors of West Asia
to Iran and Iran looked into the south
and found the connection or rather the
Europeans discovered this southern route
and then the Iranians developed that so
in a sense that kind of fabrication of
Iran also has a long history so what you
see that today the Iranians are claiming
over the control or usually when
difference policing of the Persian God
has this long history the same is with
the Caspian by the way which is people
don't hear about it much but it's in the
news because the relationship between
Iran Russia and all the other Republic's
Kazakhstan Azerbaijan Turkmenistan
Gogi Georgia all of these around the
Caspian have a long history of how they
are dealing with this body of water here
and they strategically what is the
significance of it because of the oil
resources because of the communication
between these countries and because of
the richness of the Caucasus in that in
that area which incidentally means next
much we are having a full conference and
because on the Caspian and significance
of the gas
or to that so yes so the history is it's
very important to understand the history
of Iran when looking at situations yes
yeah yeah so final questions talk about
what you conclude in your book and I'm
curious to know your thoughts on how you
think the Iranian people would react to
your book and given a copy thank you
the conclusion of the book as I pointed
out throughout we can see almost as if
there is a chain there is a line in
which I brought poetry music artistic
expressions by which Iran has always
been very proud of as a culture passion
is a language of poetry and has more at
least more than a millennium of poetry
which is very proud of well this idea of
a poetry how it changed how it changed
Iranians and I did understanding of
themselves how it actually from
expressions in words it turned into the
expressions into images because cinema
is is very important in today's Iran has
always kind of replaced poetry this I
try to look to try to take all the way
to the end of the book throughout the
book I have brought the voices of poets
artists musicians singers even popular
singers cinema filmmakers it's always
there
in bits and pieces of it is always there
the end of it I ended with possibly I
mean everybody quite a number of
reviewers looked at it and said you know
the the message that you send at the end
of the book is very enigmatic because on
the one hand it's
kind of optimistic that this culture is
going to survive on the other hand you
seem to be sending a message that this
is a very tragic history what you see in
front of us but all histories are tragic
but perhaps Iranian case is a little bit
more tragic as a matter of fact there
was a panel there was a special plenary
panel in the association of Iranian
studies months ago in Irvine there was a
panel four speakers talked about this
book which was actually quite
interesting it's very well attended
everybody came to listen and what after
speakers who was very praiseful but had
its own perspective and it has been
filmed hopefully it's going to be on the
website of the book and year press he
pointed out that well I've read this
book and the thing that most struck me
as most significant is that how tragic
this history is and I came out with this
verse which I've actually quoted from a
poet that she says the
he said she says it's a sorrowful stroll
in the garden of memories this is the
rest from fruit of a desert and I
thought this is a fascinating kind of a
summing up what this book is about
Oliver
then I went back and they say I used
that actually in the introduction that's
where I said after all when this book is
done this is a sorrowful stroll in the
garden of memory there at the end of it
I used another verse by by her again by
fluke FAFSA and it's quite accidentally
it wasn't meant to be like that but
she's one of the boys that I'm very fond
of and she says that the another verse
it's that the only thing that survives
is the voice ferret tan hosted a schema
not in person it's only the voice that
survives and then I ended with the verse
from office which is this great prince
of Persian poetry which is indeed
pleasure it's as if the Pharaohs that
was referring to this verse by office in
which again the idea is that there is
nothing under the skies better than the
voice of love I said oh yes oh honey
ish Nadi da Costa I said oh yes oh honey
a study done Costa yoga reading combated
award Vermont under this circulating and
the distro tating Dome of the universe I
cannot see a better memory than the
voice of love and I thought you know my
book is all about political history and
economic history and all of that which
gives that actually that sense of a
tragedy to this what happened to this
nation but still this voice of love is
there
and the ending of it attracted a great
deal of attention even BBC Persian which
produces a lot of films and stuff one of
their producers made a 20 minute film
about this book recently in which he
basically uses that theme at the end of
the book and tries to look back at the
course of the 20th century only of the
way that the person in this Iranian
notion of culture has evolved and then
brings this with music at the end of it
which is a excellent treatment actually
a very good take on the book so in
effect what I'm saying is that my if I
want to be a little bit less poetic my
take off this is that yes Iran is going
through a very troubled period in past
40 years I was going through a period of
crisis and if we look back actually as
this colleague said there's a plenty of
one crisis after another but I don't
think that purely political crisis is or
other very negative aspects are going to
basically define this this politically
defines the history of this country well
today it more than anything else
ecology is important Iran is suffering
from a very severe water shortage
because of the climatic climatic changes
and they are beginning to realize that
the real killer is not the United States
is not what they are facing in terms of
the all kinds of strategic issues is the
water which they don't have as much so
these are the new challenges that tend
to shape future Iran and for that matter
to all of the region as environmental
historians will tell you environment
doesn't recognize boundaries so it's the
whole of the region
let's say from Satish all the way to the
eastern Mediterranean that it's facing
the whole of North Africa it's facing
the same problem I have enjoyed
listening to you talk about your book
thank you so much for being here today
with us thank you I'm gradually occasion
for more information about professor
ammonite and his research please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
thank you so much
you